bonjour
eh ben
parmi vous c'était pas gagné d'avancé
sur le mail de l'université de savoie
pour participer astérix pour être devant
vous à ce moment précis la première
action que j'ai eu c'est non mais j'ai
pas le temps pour ça c'est une réaction
que vous avez je pense vous aussi des
fois de dire j'ai pas le temps à des
trucs et moi c'est un sujet qui me
passionne le temps et j'essaye souvent
de trouver plein de moyens de
m'organiser pour gagner du temps en
faire plus de choses dans la journée je
sais pas si ça vous arrive à vous aussi
je suis peut-être un psychopathe du
temps j'en sais rien vous allez voir si
vous vous reconnaissez dans des trucs et
et cette année par exemple j'utilise un
tracker c'est un objet connecté
j'ai associé des activités avec des
couleurs et du coup quand je travaille
tous les quarts d'heure je change de
j'essaie de changer d'activité
ça donne des trucs comme ça et du coup
ça me permet d'être graphistes vidéastes
pianiste auteur musicien entrepreneurs
plein de trucs
je veux aussi professeur de musique
j'organise des soirées de l'instant tous
les mois dans plusieurs villes de france
j'habite entre paris et lyon du coup je
prends le et chambéry du coup je prends
le train à deux fois par semaine je fais
du sport si je joue aux jeux vidéo
je suis social un peu et
bref je fais plein de choses un peu
comme vous tous et j'entends tout temps
les gens qui disent j'ai pas le temps
du coup moi ça m'énerve ça me frustre
alors j'essaie d'aider les gens qui le
dit j'ai pas le temps mais j'y arrive
pas et quand je me pose la question moi
même je me dis que j'ai pas le temps non
plus j'ai pas le temps de regarder les
génériques des séries télé parce que
j'ai déjà vu j'ai pas le temps reste et
papoter avec mes parents quand je vais
les voir
j'ai pas le temps de cuisiner je préfère
réchauffer des plats le temps au final
c'est une histoire de choix mais sûr
qu'on se batte pour choisir c'est un peu
ma question du jour avant de vous
proposer une réponse un peu personnel
avec mon ami le piano on va faire un
petit tour de ce qui existe déjà
selon l'univers le temps il à 13,8
milliards d'années en terme de temps
c'est assez immense jeu l'univers je
pense pas qu'il dit souvent j'ai pas le
temps lui et c'est un peu dur à
formaliser pour nous 13,8 milliards
d'années cascarre sagan c'est un
américain il a proposé un truc
formidable qui s'appelle le calendrier
cosmique c'est de répartir cet âge de
l'univers sur un calendrier comme le
calendrier de la poste
moi j'ai fait ça avec un match de foot
ce que c'est plus rigolo alors 6 dvd mal
c'était le big bang
et que la fin c'était ce moment présent
là aujourd'hui le système solaire il
apparaîtrait à la 65e minute de jeu et
la première vie multicellulaire sur
terre à la 81e nous les humains ce sera
seulement la dernière seconde du temps
additionnel
donc toute notre histoire du feu à la
chute de rome de l'imprimerie à internet
dans les dernières millisecondes de ce
match de l'univers si on n'a pas le
temps c'est la faute de l'univers mais
bon vous n'allez pas dire à votre prof
j'ai pas pu rendre mon exposé à cause de
l'univers j'ai pas il m'a pas laissé le
temps tout sa décision et si on se
rapprocher un peu la vie c'est quelque
chose qu'on a plus de facilité à
formaliser et on fait ça un peu toujours
de la même manière un le passé derrière
le futur devant et maintenant c'est le
présent ça implique un début la
naissance est une fin la mort est en
fait c'est assez flippant comme façon de
voir le temps parce que ça voudrait dire
que chaque moment nous rapproche de la
mort donc si on n'a pas le temps ce
parce qu'on va mourir
ok si on être un peu plus optimistes et
plus poétique les saisons notre année la
plage la raclette l'heure d'été à
l'heure d'hiver tous a séduit autant que
mais la terre tournait autour du soleil
et si la terre elle tourne autour du
soleil et qu'elle se bat repas dans
l'espace ce à cause de la gravité de la
traction du soleil la gravité c'est un
phénomène incroyable qui attire les
corps massif peu importe à distance les
uns vers les autres
et si la gravité du soleil est capable
de modifier la position de la terre dans
l'espace elle est capable de modifier sa
position dans le temps et le premier à
voir associer la gravité et le temps et
bien c'est moi dans mon album de 2019
un africain c'est einstein c'est pas la
même catégorie
ça fait plus de sens tant qu'il a
découvert qu'un observateur en fonction
de sa vitesse de sa masse de son
accélération il pouvait tordre l'espace
temps c'est assez fou comme truc hein ça
veut dire que de deux observateurs
différents n'ont pas le même temps on
dit que le temps est relatif
pour ce qu'ont vu interstellar ça prend
un peu du sens pour les autres je vous
conseille de creuser un peu le truc mais
bon c'est pareil vous n'allez pas dire à
votre copine j'ai pas pu faire la
vaisselle à lacoste d'einstein de la
relativité fois qu'on enchaîne
non il ya un truc qui est pas du tout
relatif c'est le temps des horloges ça
fait longtemps qu'ils ont la fixer notre
journée sur 24 heures et ce qui est
assez miraculeux là dedans c'est qu'on a
tous 24 heures qu'on soit blanc noir
riche pauvre on a tous 24 heures mais si
nos ancêtres
il avait besoin de plus de six heures
pour chasser un lapin le découper le
faire cuire le digérer nous il nous faut
à peine 20 minutes pour le commander
l'avoir à la maison et les hommes se
sont emparés du temps et on fait un peu
ça avec tout ils ont tous séquences et
on a tout accéléré
moi j'appelle ça le le code du temps ça
va des chiffres sur le réveil au temps
de cuisson des pâtes et ceux qui ont le
temps qu'ils n'ont rien à faire on dit
que c'était bon à rien d un cap à des
procrastinateurs des flemmards si on n'a
pas le temps c'est parce que la voir
nous rend coupable la minute c'est
incomparable une minutes d'attentes ne
sera jamais pareil qu'une minute
d'exaltation c'est dû à notre cerveau à
nos réflexes à notre instinct de survie
le temps on élit absolue ni relatif il
est émotif une minute ne passera jamais
pareil pour le père spectateurs que pour
son fils à l'assaut du but adverse
ni même pour le mec qui dort dans le
parc à côté d'ailleurs quand on dort le
temps on se demande même où il va alors
sans parler de la vie qui défile sous
nos yeux lors d'un accident repenser à
la dernière fois vous avez oublié un
truc quelque part et vous refaire tout
le chemin en sens inverse nous a rendu
fou ce sentiment de temps perdu
il venait de vous comment on peut dire
alors à quelqu'un j'ai pas le temps sans
savoir si on est sur la même sont dans
le même état émotionnel je finis ce
petit tour avec l'instant qui pour moi
est la plus belle façon de voir le temps
qui passe si on avait dit à 50 ans à
quelqu'un qui pourrait communiquer avec
n'importe qui dans le monde
instantanément nous aurait pris pour des
dieux est ce qu'on est dédiée
aujourd'hui non on dit toujours qu'on
n'a pas le temps et c'est vrai on veut
tous dans l'instant on veut les
informations les réponses les sensations
mais l'instance encore un truc personnel
l'instance est liée aux évènements et
comme on y réagit puits a depuis eu
d'événement du coup si on y réagit et
puis on a cette sensation de temps qui
passe pour moi c'est un fait avéré
les gens qui ont le plus de temps sont
ceux qui font le plus de choses
l'autre jour on parlait d'une soirée
avec quelqu'un et on se disait que dans
la soirée si ya pas de dj s il ya pas de
gros soucis a pas de jeu s'il n'y a pas
d'apéro et bats la soirée en avance par
les gens arrivent et salut et puis cela
s'ils partent moi j'organise des soirées
de l'instant et dans les soirées de
l'instant il ya une quinzaine d'artistes
qui viennent proposer des performances
non à passer à des instants et du coup
pour le spectateur il a vraiment cette
sensation de d'enchaînements
d'événements et d'émotions d'intensité
mais pour quelqu'un qui est pas dans
cette soirée c'est juste un seul
événement c'est la soirée de l'instant
et pour quelqu'un du futur ou du passé
toutes les soirées de l'instant et les
milliers d'instants qui ont eu lieu ben
c'est juste un seul événement et soirée
l'instant des années 2010 si on n'a pas
le temps c'est parce qu'on veut pas tous
le même instant on n'est pas capable de
s'organiser
on n'est pas capable de découper la vie
en une somme d'un stand qui se valent
alors on dit qu'on n'a pas le temps
c'est plus simple d'ailleurs je pense
que c'est peut-être juste ça en fait on
dit j'ai pas le temps c'est une réaction
si on n'a pas envie de dire non on n'a
pas envie de laisser les gens alors leur
dit qu'on n'a pas le temps
moi je pense que si on n'a pas le temps
c'est pas de la faute de l'univers c'est
pas de la faute de la mort c'est pas la
faute de nos émotions c'est pas de la
faute des stein
si on n'a pas le temps c'est parce qu'on
ne prend pas on l'accuse on parle à sa
place on l'utilisent comme une excuse
et moi j'aimerais que le temps nous
répondent et vous savez quoi
il va le faire maintenant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
moi c'est tout
ouais le temps je suis là j'ai
l'avantagé acquis
j'ai même pas dans mes recherches pas
tenu compte les jours
moi je compte les tours du kanak si
arthur
loin de ton aiguille sur
franchement d'une égalité
pour moi leur haletant de brouillette a
perdu je suis bien plus que ça chiant
bosseur moi j'ai pathak ans bat arrêt
maladie pas dickens sans cesse prisé
chez trion permanence
6 am à bordeaux
et sans moi ton espèce de ville
aucun sens
[Musique]
les présentations en fait qu'elle soit
de remettre les pendules au coeur
leur
c'est pas moi
c'est pas de moi tu comprends ça c'est
vos délires
c'est vous qui avait dessiné qu'une
minute ce après 66 secondes et puis une
seconde on n'a qu'à dire que c'est ça
on appellera ça une r6 a fait 60 minutes
est plutôt une année on mettrait 12 mois
anita qu'une bêtise des mois c'était
pareil c'est peut-être tout simple à
compter
et quand tu continues tu te rends compte
qu'il n'est pas m'as tu continues tu
comprends qu'ils étaient de mes yeux
tu vois je fais allumer le soleil je
peux finir les étoiles je cachais la
lune je peux faire des fils et des
filles
mais c'est pas moi le réveil kit se
coule matin à leur calme toi juni contre
toi ni pour toi pourquoi tu veux me
défier un jeu juste là c'est tout je
veux pas te b battu neuf fois
tu veux rien opus était tout à la cour
alors arrête un peu tes je trouve un
bouquet moi j'ai pas le temps et rend le
jeu vous dire prends moi france
parfois tu y arrives
je te rends même pas compte mais je
t'assure
parfois
tu m'as trahi
[Musique]
suspendu dans l'équilibré à figer le
monde pour un sourire un baiser un
regard un je t'aime un orgasme
[Musique]
et quand tu dors alors là je passe
carrément à la trappe
aix et je m'évade dans le vide
[Musique]
jusqu'à ce que tu reprennes conscience
et quand là j'en arrive là en revanche
j'ai du mal à suivre la cadence encore
une fois c'est faux qu'attend sympa la
mienne pas la peine de craindre quand le
stress que provident tu te sers comme un
serpent sans que je n'avance plus
quelques brides alors que si j'avance
c'est toi qui est sans cesse pressé tu
courent dans tous les sens n'apporte
comme en donnant leur apportant battue
c'est quoi tu es ridicule
voilà j'espère qu'en tête du temps comme
ça me dépasse et deux doublés de perené
me contrer
un concert c'est perdu d'avancé
meaux - je suis sincère c'est sûr
je relativise
mais jamais dit le contraire
si toi qui t'es fort
ceux ci
tous les humains
voulait toujours tout standardisés
basket les mêmes voitures les mêmes ça
pique
musique les mêmes films et même pierre
et moi le temps
le concept du sein très subjectif qu'ils
soient riches apparaît partout dans
toutes les têtes
n'importe quoi
voyage à l'autre bout du monde
il va me dire que je suis pareil partout
je ferai bien qu'ils contrôlent qui
tout est à tout contrôler
[Musique]
regardez la nature si c'est pas une
belle bande de nombreuses
moi je vous dis hein on nous répond
possible
je suis un no de la tuque dépenses
je suis l'explosion de la galaxie
[Musique]
alors quand je vois private yeux là ça
me fout un peu les boules
je sais que la crème passer au dessus
mais quand même des millions d'années
pour en arriver à ce que vous êtes
et je n'ai pas un petit hommage de temps
en temps j'avoue je suis déçu
ya bien eu deux ou trois personnages
leurs chronos sont était un parmi
d'autres que vous l'avez vite zappé si
vous mangez
ça va que j'ai pas de problème d'ego
parce que franchement c'est pas cool je
suis pas quelqu'un parmi d'autres moi je
suis le temps
si j'arrêtais de mes collègues ton petit
monde entrepôts centres est là et bien
il s'écroule ret eo
au fond c'est pas grave
fait au moins d'en vouloir tout le temps
pour tout et n'importe quoi
un coup je passe trop vite
akkouche passe très lentement le coup tu
t'ennuies
un coup tu cours trop un coup tu envie
de faire pipi c'est bon
accepté moi tout simplement
allez viens
on fait la paix
[Applaudissements]